december
1950
time had no meaning
we labored through infinite darkness in
ghostly clouds of snow
over an icy path that rose and fell
but seemed to lead nowhere
we saw only the back of the man ahead a
hunched figure
in a long shapeless parka whose every
tortured step
was an act of will
we carried on with the only strength
that was left
to us marine corps discipline
over the noise the wind we heard chinese
soldiers speaking
they were no more than 25 yards away but
we could not see them
undoubtedly they heard us too but in the
blinding snow
they mistook our column for one of their
own
the nearby chinese voices had an
adrenaline effect
realizing that we were within grenade
range
we were charged with energy and our
minds cleared
gone was our weary stumbling the men
became
sure-footed alert the nightmare
passagewheed endured through the dark
frigid storm
was ended we had reached the enemy
the men held their fire and watched for
signaled orders
no unlikely noise gave away our presence
lee signaled his squads into skirmishers
extending to both sides quietly he led
them forward on hands and knees
the enemy's first shots came as our
rifleman topped the rise
a torrent of oaths and fire erupted from
the marines
as they poured across a small chinese
position
an enemy squad had been sleeping on a
wide shelf of ground that jutted from
the hillside
most of them were shot in the brief
firefight one was bayonetted in his hole
a few ran off into the snow
there was no longer any need for silence
lee and his ncos bellowed orders to
reform the skirmish line
then sent the rifleman in pursuit up the
hill
the night exploded with the flash and
sound of the fight
the marines had the advantage of
surprise and momentum
they fought with a fierce energy now
released from the hours of cold and
misery
the chinese could do little more than
try to escape
their position was a wide plateau
studded with large granite boulders
the snowy field was packed with small
holes and rocks
from which the startled chinese emerged
many of them were unarmed and most ran
off to the south
those with weapons attempted to fight
the knight was against them under the
ghostly blue illumination from the
mortars
teams of parka-clad marines using
automatic weapons
bayonets and grenades blasted through
the chinese who stayed to face them
baker company quickly secured a
perimeter
despite the prodding of the ncos many of
the men fell asleep
others nodded off while in the act of
repeating their orders
colonel davis walked the line with the
platoon commanders
he assured that officers and ncos were
prepared against counter-attack
and ordered 25 watch one man awake
in four
dawn arrived gray and cold
and we jumped off on the second phase of
the breakthrough
abel and baker attacked online headed
for fox hill a thousand yards away
minutes after we moved out kaiser's
platoon on the left
walked into heavy small arms and machine
gun fire from a ridge on his flank
the 60s responded with h.e on the ridge
and kaiser's people broke through
deep snow to mount the hill
when they neared the ridgeline we lifted
the mortar fire
and the platoon drove through the enemy
position on its own firepower
we were astonished by our first view of
fox hill
the snow field that led up to the
embattled company's position
was covered with hundreds of dead
chinese soldiers
many of them seem to sleep under
blankets of drifted snow
but their bodies were frozen in spasms
of pain
there were jumbles of corpses and padded
green uniforms
a white clad column had fallen in the
formation that it attracted the
attention of fox companies
machine gunners craters of dirt and snow
made by the big guns were rimmed with
bodies
and parts of men thick bands of dead
chinese
lay at the base of fox company's
perimeter
we stood in wonder
men bowed their heads in prayer some
fell to their knees
breathed quiet oaths of disbelief
tears came to the eyes of the raggedy
marines who had endured
the bitter cold and savage battle to
reach this place of suffering
and courage
someone let loose a wild cheer
and we broke forward in a jubilant run
across the snow-covered and
corpse-filled battlefield
the marines of fox company waved
brightly colored banners
the blue yellow and red remnants of the
parachute drops
that had sustained them for nearly a
week
around their perimeter fox company had
constructed barricades
of frozen chinese bodies
from behind these walls of dead the
marines had mounted their weapons
and maintained the fight against an
enemy whose numbers
never ceased
now the men of fox company arose from
behind these gruesome piles to join us
arm slings and blood-soaked compresses
were common among them
men hobbled about with makeshift leg
splints
all hands were haggard and dirty as were
we
we exchanged profane greetings that did
not conceal
the love that we marines felt for each
other
the sun came out later and marines
appeared upon the skylines
to the north then we saw marines
marching down the msr
toward us their columns of riflemen at
first
followed by a long trail of vehicles and
artillery pieces
our corsairs swooped in close their
crooked wings
wagging in salute the fifth and seventh
marines
had broken out of you dom knee
but still they had to travel 14 miles
to get to the american base at haggaroo
re
one of jack's buddies responding to a
spasm of diarrhea was nailed by a sniper
galapa went to help the man who cried in
pain
as he flailed about in the snow he had
just soiled he pulled his buddy to cover
but the sniper's next bullet
caught galepo in the lower back ed
topple the only corman left to us was
hit in the leg sometime that day
it was a flesh wound painful at first
but the cold
deadened it topple was not about to turn
himself in
he patched up his own leg chomped on a
cigar
and limped about taking care of his
marines
we had lost scores of good men
sergeant bondurant the corpsman
doktorski sergeant swan dollar the big
squad leader from first platoon
sherman richter the machine gun sergeant
dean westberg and jim veter workhorse
murder men hugo johnson was a severe
loss to me
he and kelly were the only ncos i had
left both
corporals sergeant richard had been hit
twice
but he was still with us richard
and gunny foster were the remaining
senior ncos
foster kept the machine guns but became
the company gunnery sergeant when
buckley had turned in
all of the platoon sergeants had been
hit
as were most of the squad leaders we had
corporals and privates
stepping into leadership billets but
they were combat experienced marines
and they knew the work
the marine column that came out of the
besieged udami knee
had hundreds of jeeps ambulances and
trucks
as well as big guns of the artillery
regiment
many of the trucks were filled with
wounded men and some were stacked with
the corpses
of our killed in action
while the rifle companies secured the
high ground the column crept along the
road often grinding to a halt
stop and start pace made it vulnerable
to bands of
chinese who infiltrated the road
the walking wounded who could carry a
weapon were turned to rifleman to
protect the column
every man who could walk hobble or limp
was ordered off the trucks
the only riders were the serious cases
the gut wounds
and blinded men those with severe leg
wounds
and men with frostbite so bad they would
need amputation
many of the wounded died in the trucks
some froze to death
and some were shot by infiltrators
the 14 mile ride was three days and
nights of grim's survival
bob fisher who could hardly field his
wounded leg anymore and was worried that
he would lose it was ordered off the
truck and given flank guard
duty a limping sergeant
shoved a rifle at him and ordered him to
fix bayonet
lock and load and stand by to repel
borders
the walking wounded fought off the
chinese and did not let them get to the
trucks
[Music]
it was like that all the way to hoggaroo
re
the rifle companies of the 5th and
seventh marines
stayed in the hills guarding the msr as
the column
pulled into hagaroo re
the garrison of the town came out to
meet the bedraggled marines
who would run the 14-mile gauntlet of
fire
and ice there were trucks and jeeps with
their windshield shot away
and their hoods and sides peppered with
bullet holes and gashed by shrapnel
wounded men were stuffed in layers in
the backs of the trucks
others were lashed across the hoods or
tied to the fenders
there were many more trucks filled with
corpses than had started the journey
as the walking wounded came within sight
of the town
someone commanded them to fall into
ranks
maybe it was the limping sergeant who
gave the command the old salt
who would set the defenses along bob
fisher's stretch of the column
it could have been father griffin or
sergeant winget
or corporal burris or corporal johnson
the wounded men and some who were
unharmed but who staggered from
exhaustion
formed up into three files
shouldered their weapons and marched
in ragged step
slowly the tread of their thick
rubber-soled shoe packs on the icy road
became a steady sure cadence
and the haggard and hurt marines put
their heads high
captain wilcox who couldn't carry a
weapon was in the forward ranks
his arm was in a huge cast and splinted
so that it was horizontal to
the deck his head and face were a cocoon
of bandages
but holding himself erect
he picked up the cadence and marched
standing straight
a battalion surgeon took time away from
the hundreds of wounded men he tended
in the hagaroo re-aid station to witness
the column's arrival
those bastards those magnificent
bastards
were the words the doctor used to
describe
the worn and torn marines from you
domney
and that is from the book colder than
hell
by joseph r owen who was
a mortar platoon commander in baker
company
first battalion seventh marines
and we covered that harrowing
book in podcast number 53 in
2016 but i always think
i always think about that part of the
story
i always think about that moment
i always think about these marines
exhausted and bloodied and frozen
and wounded and carrying their fellow
marines
who were killed in action
and i think of them at that point of
misery
and suffering and fatigue and i think of
them
falling into ranks and standing up
straight
and marching
marching proudly with their heads held
high
even though they knew
they knew there was more fighting and
freezing
and suffering to come
and i think that is a good example
a good example for me to follow a good
example for all of us to follow
when the when the times are tough and
the challenges
just keep piling up
and i know it's been a year of many
challenges
throughout the world
and they keep piling up political
hostilities and
civil strife and the virus and economic
struggles
it's been a challenging year
to say the least
but you know what
we are still here
we are still in the game we have not
been
defeated
so stand up straight
stand up straight and march forward
and give someone else some encouragement
let them see you standing strong set
an example
and if you set an example if you lead
you know what
other people will join in
the fortitude will spread
the cadence will align the movement
will grow and we
will march forward
we will march forward together into the
future
into 2021
with our heads held high
ready for whatever comes our way
and by our very posture by our very
being
we will let the world know
that we are here
to win
happy new year everybody
and stand by to get some